so hi everyone my name is Andy Robin
Ellie I'm a senior Rd scientist in gene
editing and novel modalities at Miller
for Sigma
the life science business of Merck KGaA
darmstadt germany operates as nila for
Sigma in the US and Canada so genomics
has become this critical foundation for
how the field of drug discovery is
moving forward nowadays specifically
functional genomics and the ability to
capture these large highly informative
datasets allows for rapid construction
and dissection of gene pathways that
govern cell functions and physiology and
the ability to collect and assemble this
information for individual patients
really only increases the power of
discovery in personalized medicine today
I want to talk about some of the awesome
tools and platforms that are being used
to drive discovery using unbiased
forward genetic screening
so screening strategies have really
evolved over the past couple decades
from swinging blindly in the dark with
random mutagenesis growing into more
educated approaches in the age of genome
sequencing with orcs and RNA I libraries
until we've arrived in this golden era
of CRISPR with high precision high
efficiency targeting for controlled
manipulation of the genome milah four
Sigma's had a committed role in this
story of functional genomics and genome
engineering tools over the past decade
and we maintain a strong footprint in
the CRISPR IP landscape most recently
with the awarding of a US patent for our
proxy CRISPR technology
so CRISPR genome editing is a tool can
be used to achieve a wide variety of
genetic modification gene knockouts
probably the most common option shown
here but later we'll get into more
detail on targeting these first two
features in CRISPR activation and
inhibition and really the take-home
message here is that we can harness the
power of CRISPR technology to enable
virtually any genomic manipulation
desire
so the ease at which one can use CRISPR
tools to target many genes at once as
really opened up the possibilities and
accessibility for whole genome screening
because there's no need to engineer a
targeting protein for each gene instead
we rely on these short non-coding RNA
guides that can be transfected or
expressed along with a version of calf
nine
whole genome screens using CRISPR are
unbiased and they allow for discovery of
drug and disease relevant pathways and
loss of function and gain of function
CRISPR screens are complementary to one
another
screens are high-throughput they yield
up to whole genome resolution old
screens allow for rapid identification
of lists of target genes while arrayed
screens are perfect for high content
imaging and cellular phenotyping and
they're efficient and accessible guides
are designed strategically for optimal
targeting to increase confidence in
phenotypic specificity and they require
much less development time and really
cost than a protein based screen would
so there are two primary types of
screens that you can do with CRISPR
pooled screens which combine thousands
of guide RNAs in a single tube and
arrayed screens which consists of
thousands of unique wells of individual
guide RNA
pulled screens are most widely used and
pretty straightforward upfront but they
require much more of a time investment
on the back end during data
deconvolution and validation arrayed
screens on the other hand require a more
substantial upfront investment of labor
but they can yield a broader diversity
of data points with much less back-end
effort because of all of the data having
been already collected but the general
workflow for these two types of crisper
screens is pretty much the same
so when people talk about uses of
crisper and crisper mediated gene
editing they're usually talking about
nucleus based creation of
double-stranded breaks when using
nucleus base CRISPR technologies really
relying on the endogenous DNA repair
mechanisms to achieve the desired
modification these outcomes are achieved
either through NH AJ or homology
directed repair or HDR there are some
tools and strategies that can shift this
balance a little bit but it's not really
your choice which mechanism the cell
uses to repair the double-stranded break
and it predominantly uses nhej a often
resulting in loss of function mutations
caused by frame shift insertions or
deletions
however the full extent of crispers
utility really extends beyond just
targeted cutting of DNA nucleus
independent applications of CRISPR
provide all of that targeting
specificity but for cargo delivery the
most used of which is for gene
regulation
Christopher can be used to activate or
inhibit transcription by targeting
around the transcriptional start side of
a gene and delivering effector domains
to either attract or repel the
transcriptional machinery these
applications use a nuclease dead version
of task 9 called decaf 9 which harbors
point mutations that inactivate DNA
cleavage function
so while crisper a technology has
evolved over time into more creative and
powerful activators crisperize has
really remained relatively unchanged due
to its high temp Tory efficiency
a number of CRISPR activators exist
including a different one of their own
George church's lab published a nice
comparison paper showing that the CRISPR
Sam system is the superior activator
across the different flavors this result
was validated recently in IPS CS by the
Mexico peon lab at the Wellcome Trust
Sanger Institute but this is the CRISPR
technology we chose to develop an offer
but what is CRISPR Sam
dinner gistic activation mediator or
stam was created by fen John's lab at
the Broad Institute and it's a powerful
three part CRISPR based transcriptional
activator complex at its core here is
the decays 9bt 64 fusion proteins that
forms this basic synthetic transcription
factor
it complexes with a guide RNA is normal
to form the RMT targeting complex but
the stem and tetra loops of the guide
scaffold have been modified to contain
RNA aptamers that bind an MS to viral
coat protein ms 2 is inert on its own
but it serves to deliver this cargo p65
and hsf 1 transcriptional co-activators
to the RNP complex upon dimerization
when it comes to a targeting strategy
and guide design CRISPR a and CRISPR I
are comparatively much simpler than
CRISPR nuclease designing a guide for
knockout requires gene specific design
each gene needs to be targeted
independently targeted exons must be
shared between all isoforms so
alternative splice forms
can't compensate the target site must be
early enough in the gene to ensure
complete loss of functions but not so
early that you may allow usage of an
alternative or cryptic start codon
activation and inhibition on the other
hand have more Universal Guide design
rules targeting bases surrounding the
transcriptional start side of a gene
meaning that one guide can capture all
of the splice variants because of this
specificity you can have a much higher
confidence in your guides and you can
worry much less about off target
activity but the diagram on the right
shows the targeting window for
activation 50 to 200 base pairs upstream
of the transcriptional start site
inhibition is similar targeting the
minus 52 plus 200 window surrounding
that TSS
so using the original CRISPR Sam
plasmids you can see that the activator
capabilities of the system are really
quite amazing
this qrt-pcr amplification curve shows
that each guide to opt for increases
expression above baseline by about nine
to ten cycles to the right you can see
relative gene expression quantification
for a couple of different genes showing
strong transcriptional activation for
both human and mouse guides using
plasmid DNA
however when we went to produce
lentiviral particles for these we found
that the original vectors were unable to
make a sufficient amount of packaged
functional virus to meet the needs of
our customers so this is an echoed by
people who have acquired these libraries
from other sources on the left you can
see raw viral particles quantified
packaged functional virus is on the
right so we modified the vector backbone
to improve viral production and optimize
the system for improved transcriptional
efficiencies including putting a G in
the first position of the guide that was
missing so our modified vector backbone
produces substantially higher levels of
functional virus now without this
improvement for this sample here to
transduce hundred thousand cells in a
single well 212 well plates you'd have
to add 40 mils of mostly empty virus to
get appropriate transduction with the
improved vector you only need about 10
microliters of virus
so our new functional tighter for Sam
meets the efficiency required for whole
genome screening with a pooled library
of guides
so why should you add crisper a and
crisper a screening to your toolbox
crisper a is complementary to existing
loss-of-function technologies as each
enriches four different sets of genes
responsible for the same phenotype
unlike loss-of-function technologies
prefer a is fairly unique for
gain-of-function screening
to achieve loss of function with a
CRISPR nucleus the Cassadine needs to
create a double-stranded break that
happens to be repaired in such a way
that in in Dell either causes a
frameshift or disrupts a functional
domain in each copy of the gene
when performing a knock out screen and a
cancer cell line we often have to worry
about the ability to completely knock
out high copy number genes due to
aneuploidy and none of these are
concerns for activation screens because
only one copy of the target gene is
needed the targeting complex just needs
to bind to one copy and recruit the
co-activators
with D cast 9 based systems there's no
real risk of genome instability from
double-stranded breaks as there's no
cutting and by activating transcription
at the endogenous locus instead of
transgenic over expression of a defined
isoform that means the cell can choose
which isoform expression and splice
variation it uses in a more
physiologically relevant manner setting
this technology apart from warp screens
we currently offer custom pools and
off-the-shelf whole genome libraries for
human and mouse in this system
but while gain-of-function crisper
screening is obvious in its
complimentary relationship to
traditional CRISPR knockout screening
CRISPR I actually offers unique
complementarity to both systems
historically shrna has captured the
market share for loss-of-function
screening tools Chris Berg has provided
an excellent alternative to Rai with the
promise of complete gene knock out but
knocked down technology still have other
key advantages which is why shRNA is
really still such a popular member of
our functional genomics portfolio
however it's been shown that CRISPR I
delivers much more significant
phenotypes per target gene and shRNA
does in this case looking at the
response of k562 cells to rice and
toxins with top hits from each screen
you can see a nearly across-the-board
improvement in phenotypic significance
for all the top hits from these screens
another screen was performed to explore
the gene pathways that govern the
sensitizing and protective responses to
a cholera diphtheria toxin fusion the
author's capitalized on an orthogonal
validation strategy of pairing CRISPR I
and CRISPR a in parallel and this figure
really highlights the significance of
specific biosynthetic pathways that
modulate the sensitivity phenotype so
here you can see that each technology
identified different pathways and
different genes for the same pathways
here CRISPR a identified targets and
here the targets that CRISPR I
identified several of these topics shown
here match blue and red show
complementary phenotypes for the same
target when screens using CRISPR a and
crisperize illustrating the strengths of
pairing these two screening platforms
together
for I technology has been described in
great detail by the labs of Luke Gilbert
and John Weissman at UCSF this figure
shows the optimal targeting window for
CRISPR I here in orange much like CRISPR
a as before it operates within a fairly
specific targeting window surrounding
that transcriptional start the Weissman
lab has updated their guide design
strategy for Herzberg I over the years
and it's improved substantially based on
optimized guide algorithms and machine
learning and most recently incorporates
nucleosome positioning data to improve
genomic accessibility so here they show
how the predicted guide activity has
improved with each iteration of guide
design optimization
so multiple groups have published sky
design algorithms for CRISPR we sought
to determine which guide design yields
the best knockdown and focused on
targets identified as hard to repress
the small summary of the data here but
it shows that the guide design algorithm
from the Gilbert and Weissman labs
results in optimum gene knockdown and
we're offering guides and libraries from
this latest version of their design
Wiseman lab also conducted a series of
guide RNA sequence modifications to
improve transcription and guides
abilities they identified putative RNA
polymerase 3 termination signal and
found that CRISPR transcription was
enhanced by flipping to a and u
nucleotides to prevent early termination
additionally they found that by
extending the length of the stem loop
guide stability was enhanced within
cells the cumulative effect of these two
improvements is really piqued CRISPR
efficiency
performed our own evaluation of the
improved guide scaffold using genes that
we found to be easy to knock down in
several of our cell lines a k1 and s one
on the right and genes described to be
difficult to efficiently inhibit by
calnexin on the left and our results
show that the improved guide RNA
scaffold enhances CRISPR knockdown
efficiency for nearly every guide we've
tested
but as I mentioned before CRISPR i
technology has remained relatively
unchanged since its development in 2013
but does CRISPR I benefit from the same
type of improvements as CRISPR a does
with additional effector domains a
recent paper in Nature Methods
described a targeted approach to find
new CRISPR repressors that might benefit
knockdown so they identified mecp2 which
is a chromatin modifying gene involved
in Rhett syndrome and fused its
transcriptional repressor domain to D
Cassadine crab
although mecp2 is thought to perform
other cellular functions the authors
reported that it enhanced CRISPR eye for
art to repress target genes
we performed a fairly comprehensive
comparison of all the different
combinations of guide modifications
guide designs and these competing
effectors to figure out which one would
be best for our customers however our
evaluation did not identify any
instances or dozens of guides where the
mecp2 construct was superior over crafty
cast nine especially when combined with
the improved guide RNA scaffold and the
UCSF guide design
as additional improvements we used D
Cassadine with an in terminal craft
fusion that further improves knockdown
efficiency as supported by Stanley
cheese lab and have now incorporated a
Yuko element in the promoter stabilize
gene expression
but during this evaluation we analyzed
the gene expression profiles of stable
cell lines containing either crafty
Cassadine or D Cassadine crab mecp2
using single-cell RNA seek so with the
non targeting control guide only the
expression profile of crafty Cassadine
cells was found to be similar to the
parental cell line here possible that
the crab mecp2 compound effector has
some promiscuous activity on the genome
in a targeting independent manner that
results in an expression profile drift
from the parental cell line so in this T
sneak plot each dot here represents a
single cell in this analysis Dell's with
more closely related gene expression
clustered together and you can see that
the purple and the orange points cluster
together those are the crab and the
parental cell lines whereas the green
mecp2 points segregate without this kind
of analysis this consequence would
likely have gone unnoticed by us so it's
important for your experiments that your
modified helper cell line remains as
faithful to your parental cell line as
possible for all of these reasons we've
developed our CRISPR I system and
libraries based on crafty cast nine and
the improved guide designs and scaffolds
described by the labs at UCSF so we
remain confident that our combination of
CRISPR I components is the best knock
down system available
so why should you add CRISPR I and
CRISPR I screening to your toolbox
prefer I is complementary to existing
gain-of-function and loss of function
technologies
unlike RNA I CRISPR I doesn't compete
for any endogenous cellular machinery
by permanently inhibiting June function
at the level of transcription using
CRISPR I we can observe increased
knockdown efficiency over RNA I that has
to keep disrupting the translation of
continuously transcribed mRNAs
the analogy here is you have a boat
that's taking on water it's more
efficient to plug the holes rather than
continuously bailing water we can now
also target non-coding RNAs or
inhibition with much more reliable loss
of function than would be possible with
CRISPR nucleases and unlike CRISPR s9
which needs to cut the DNA and create
function breaking in del CRISPR I
increases the odds of disrupting gene
function by only requiring binding at
the complex to each copy of the locus
and although crisper I can yield up to
99% knockdown efficiency in complete
loss of function can reveal essential
genes that would otherwise be overlooked
in a knockout screen
you
those who want to explore more focused
corners of the genome we offer custom
and soon off-the-shelf sub libraries
that categorize the genome into
functional groupings like the druggable
genome and non-coding genes
so although crisper screening is pretty
straightforward
and should not be thought of as scary to
undertake there are a number of
considerations to take before you start
the screen screens take reagents and
they take manpower really tight you need
to understand the ins and outs of your
cell line as it pertains to karyotype
proliferation rates drug resistance and
transduction efficiency you need to
understand the effect of your drug on
your cells for example how long do you
need to screen with your drug to get a
good enrichment to our phenotype or more
simple example does a practical amount
of your drug kill yourself in a
practical amount of time
and you need to have clear expectations
for your phenotypic outcome is it cell
death or proliferation
can you reliably assay a functional
change in reporter fluorescence or
enzyme activity for example
next-gen sequencing requires expertise
in the use of specialized equipment or
access to it and in bioinformatics
support and you need to try to
anticipate how you'll go about
validating and following up on your top
hits these are all pretty standard
considerations but we just want you to
remember to include them in your
planning for a CRISPR screen
when it comes to next-gen sequencing to
collect the fruits of your labor you'll
want to consider the number of samples
and the size of your data set you want
to maintain enough coverage during your
screens so that you don't have
artificial dropout of guides you'll want
to start with a large enough population
of cells to transduce
because you'll be subsampling at each
step after you harvest your genomic DNA
or PCR amplification you'll also want to
take measures to preserve as much
diversity as possible and maintain
representation of guides this means
you'll be doing a lot of PCR reactions
to amplify from as many unique genomes
collected as possible
we recommend maintaining about a 300 to
500 X coverage per guide throughout your
screening process
so for a library subtool with about
20,000 dives that means you'll expect
about 10 million reads to achieve that
depth there are a number of NGS
platforms available so you'll need to
understand the capacity of the one you
plan on using for your analysis a single
my cp3 flow cell for example gives about
25 million reads meaning you'd be able
to fit two samples on this slow cell
maximize your experimental efficiency by
figuring out your mass before you start
your screen
finally we've been talking a lot about
using these large format screens to
narrow down a list of relevant target
gene candidates but to take a deeper
functional genomics dive we can now
combine CRISPR screening with single
cell analysis but we've partnered with
10x genomics to develop compatible
reagents for crisper and crisper AI that
allow for individual targets or custom
pools to explore the transcriptional
changes in single cells for more
in-depth phenotypic analysis the
strategy is perfectly suited for
following up on top hits from a whole
genome screen using small or focused
pools and we've been seeing a lot of
excitement in the field of this recently
and we're very excited about the
possibilities for further development
here
Bart NX compatible vectors contain one
of four different capture sequences here
on the left the facilitate guide
identification in each cell on the right
you can see knocked out efficiency
across the different capture sequences
or one of our recommended positive
control guys
because we've observed differences in
capture efficiency for each capture
sequence between different cell lines
we've created an optimization kit with
controls containing each of the capture
sequences allowing you to determine
which is the best capture strategy for
your cell line in your experiment we
recommend starting with that
you
but before we end I just want to take a
brief step back to knockout screening
while pooled screening has been
predominantly performed using mortalized
cancer cell lines there's a growing need
for functional genomic platforms that
are amenable to passage limited primary
cells
traditionally cast nine or D cast nine
expressing zel lines are established
prior to the delivery of the guide pool
at stable cells primary cells that can't
be cultured for longer periods of time
just don't have this kind of time a
recent paper though detailed a
successful screen using a two-step
delivery strategy that allows for
transient nucleus of casting proteins
following linty guide pool delivery that
revealed key regulators of immune
function in primary human t-cells
and we recently deposited a paper in bio
archive that shows high functionality of
CRISPR nutcases
to drive gene knockouts and primary
t-cells as well with greater specificity
than calf nine so we're very excited
about the prospects of banding the power
of CRISPR and crisper screening for drug
discoveries
now using primary human t-cells and you
can see more about this in our portfolio
online
so I hope you come away from this talk
excited to explore CRISPR and
specifically CRISPR transcriptional
regulators and screening tools to
enhance your research pipeline and if
you have any questions that come up
later please feel free to email me and
check out our expanding portfolio at
sigma-aldrich comm slash CRISPR and
thanks for listening
you